What can happen when a beam of light is incident
on the surface of any
object?.
When a light beam is incident on the surface
of any object, a part of
the light can be REFLECTED by the object...a
part of the light can be
TRANSMITTED... that is it may pass THROUGH
the object and get out from the
other side… and a part of the light can
also be ABSORBED by the object.
The amount of light reflected, absorbed or
transmitted depends on the
MATERIAL that the object is made up of.
If an object is opaque, then it will
absorb and or reflect most of the light back.
If it is transparent, more light will
be transmitted...
Can you think of examples for these two?
The Surface of a mirror is shiny and opaque,
and most of the light rays are
REFLECTED from it!
On the other hand, glass is an example of
a transparent
object.
It will TRANSMIT most of the light.
So what is REFRACTION of light?
Here’s how we define it in simple words.
It is
simply bending of light when it travels from
one medium to another!
Yes, if it is
incident at this angle, then it goes through
at another angle!
Now, this is not
the exact definition as there are a few technicalities
involved.
Let me explain it to you.
Consider a transparent object kept here, say
a glass slab.
Suppose light
travelling through air is incident obliquely
on the surface of the glass.
What do
I mean when I say ‘obliquely’?
It means ‘slant’.
It implies that the incident ray is
neither parallel nor at a right angle to a
specified line.
Now this light will BEND at the boundary of
the two media.
Here, the two
media are air and glass.
This bending of light at the boundary of the
two media
is what we call ‘refraction of light’.
We see that at this point, the light bends!
It’s not going straight.
What are these two mediums called?
The medium from where the light is
incident is called the incident medium and
the medium where refraction
occurs is called a refractive medium.
Similarly here as well, the light is travelling
from one medium to another
medium.
It’s from glass to air!
And here also it is incident at an angle.
Since we
know that air is a transparent medium, light
bends at this boundary, and
travels through air.
So light refracted at these two points!
Let us draw a line perpendicular to the surface
at this point of incidence.
This
line is also called a normal.
What is this angle called?
It is called the ANGLE OF
INCIDENCE and is denoted by the letter ‘i’.
It is an angle made by an incident
ray with the normal.
And this is the angle made by refracted ray
with the
normal.
It is called ANGLE OF REFRACTION, ‘r’.
Now there might be various questions that
you have!
Why does refraction occur?
Why does light change its direction after
entering
another medium at an angle?
Why does incident light have to be slant in
order
to change its direction?
Can the refraction occur if the light enters
perpendicular to the surface?
We will answer all these questions in the
coming videos!